Some Easter Eggs are so well hidden that we
feel the animators at Disney don’t want
us to see them.
Then there are some that are so blatant that
we can hardly call them Easter Egg because
it’s not really mysterious.
When a hidden gem is hard to spot but creative
we know that we have stumbled across a great
Disney Easter Egg, especially when we have
to pause the film to spot it.
Don’t forget to like, comment subscribe
and while you are at it, join the notification
squad for cool videos like this every day.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Paused
Movie Moments Disney Wants You
To See.
Finding Dory
Remember Nemo’s fellow captives at the dentist
office in Finding Nemo, well Nemo wasn’t
the only one to escape his niece’s grip
of death.
At the end of Finding Nemo they make their
escape too and if you’re a diehard Disney
fan you know they showed up again at the end
of Finding Dory.
Pause the scene and take a look at Jocks bag;
his is the only one that is not lined with
algae.
Don’t forget that he was the one who was
obsessed with a clean tank, looks like his
OCD paid off because we can only wonder how
long they have been in those bags.
Monsters, Inc.
The details placed on characters are important
to animators, just take a look at Sully and
his 2.3 million strands of individual hair
that were animated for Monsters, Inc..
On the scare floor is a character that runs
the entire floor and when there is a code
2319 it’s his job to alert the CDA.
He’s got a stressful job so it is fitting
for him to have the lines of an EKG on his
skin.
An awesome and appropriate design on an over
worked character.
Cars
Anyone who is a fan of Screen Rant and all
of you should be, knows that we love to talk
about the Pixar Luxo ball as much as Disney
loves to show it.
Sometimes they display the ball blatantly
like in Toy Story and other times they like
to tuck it away in a corner like Inside Out.
In the film Cars they had to get creative
because the characters in this film can’t
grab or kick the ball around.
When the town of Radiator Springs turns on
at night with all thier neon glory, look at
Sarge’s Surplus Hut sign.
It’s hidden right there.
Do you know which year the Luxo Ball made
its first appearance?
Was it 1983, 1986 or 1991?
Stay tuned to the end of our video to find
out.
Inside Out
The memory orbs in the movie Inside Out have
many hidden Easter Eggs in them but only one
when it comes to pizza.
No, not bad pizza covered in broccoli but
the famous Pizza Planet Truck.
The Pizza Planet truck has been in almost
every Pixar film and Inside Out is no exception.
When Joy, Sadness and Bing Bong are driving
on the Train of Thought take a look at the
Memory Orb in the crate.
Maybe that’s why Riley was upset about the
broccoli pizza; she wanted her usual slice
from Pizza Planet.
The Good Dinosaur
The Good Dinosaur is an adorable film about
a young dinosaur named Arlo and a cave boy
named Spot.
During their adventure Arlo is spooked and
falls back into a lake, as he splashes down
you can see Hank from Finding Dory.
Now we know why Hank doesn’t want to go
back into the ocean, if we saw a dinosaur
we would probably keep our distance too.
True or False, Anna Paquin refused a role
in The Good Dinosaur due to scheduling conflicts
with her HBO show True Blood?
Stick around to the end of our video to find
out the answer.
A Bug’s Life
P.T.
Fleas Circus goes from show to show on a train
but did you realize that train pays homage
to Disney’s 1941 animated film Dumbo?
The train is partly made out of a box from
a product called Casey Jr. Cookies and the
train from Dumbo is called Casey Jr.
When you see the side of the box, pause the
film and look at the top left corner.
It says this is a product from the company,
“J. Grant Bakery” and J Grant stands for
Disney legend Joe Grant, who was the co-writer
of Dumbo.
Beauty and the Beast
When Belle’s father, Maurice gets lost in
the forest he tries to use old signs to help
his way back home.
Even though the paint is wearing off, we are
sure that he is able to still read the sign,
which explains why he is still lost.
The sign says Valencia and Anaheim.
Almost everyone knows that Anaheim is the
city where Disneyland is located but what
is the significance of Valencia?
Valencia where the famous Cal Arts School
is located and taught numerous animators.
Toy Story
Tim Allen wasn’t the first choice to play
Buzz Lightyear in Toy Story and it’s hard
to imagine anyone else in that role but we’ll
get back to that in a moment.
Tim Allen rose to stardom from the TV show
Home Improvement where he played a TV show
host of a tool time show sponsored by Binford
Tools.
When Buzz helps to free Woody by removing
a toolbox from on top of his prison, take
a look at the company that made the toolbox.
That’s right, looks like Tool Time’s sponsorship
paid off.
Fill in the blank, Billy blank was asked to
play Buzz Light Year in Toy Story before Tim
Allen accepted the role.
We’ll reveal the answer in just a moment.
Cars 2
Not all Easter Eggs show up during the movie
itself, they can also show up during the end
credits.
This is one of the reasons to stick around
to the end of the movie, even if that movie
isn’t a superhero film.
In Cars 2 as the credits roll by you can see
Luxo Jr. lamp sitting on top of the world.
Maybe this is symbolism to Pixar/Disney being
the number one animation company out there.
World Domination!
The Incredibles
When Mr. Incredible shows up to his wedding
a little behind schedule, Elastigirl is already
ready for him at the alter.
She’s not the only one who has been waiting
for him though, if you pause the screen when
they show the wedding guests you might recall
a few friends that received cape crusader
mishaps.
Check out Thunder Head, the charmer who accidentally
takes a flight with a missile.
Or Stratogirl who got a little too close to
a jet turbine, or Metoman and his ill-fated
elevator ride and let us not forget Dinoguy.
We guess Edna is right, no capes.
There you have it ten Paused Movie Moments
Disney Wants You To See.
Here are the answers to our trivia questions:
The Luxo Ball made its first appearance in
1986’s Luxo Jr.
Anna Paquin was in The Good Dinosaur as Ramsey
the T-rex so the answer is false.
Lastly, Billy Crystal was asked to play Buzz
Light Year in Toy Story before Tim Allen accepted
the role.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.